Pues estoy todavía 1 poco tocado
porque la verdad es que lo el ojo izquierdo
que es donde más eh
me me echó ese gas pimienta.
Este individuo
pues eh, está afectado
y y poco a poco y espero IR recuperándolo,
¿pero VA a requerir su tiempo no?
¿Entonces? Bueno pues eh,
ayer fue 1 día muy largo y muy complicado
porque yo a las 2 de la madrugada
estaba interponiendo
la denuncia a la comisaría de la archancha,
todavía después de salir del debate de la televisión
pública vasca de TV
y y bueno, pues eh, fue algo muy desagradable,
fue 1 susto. Gracias a Dios no, no ha pasado nada grave,
pero bueno,
¿pues fueron unas horas muy muy complicadas no?